and joining me now exclusively is acting
ice director mark Morgan all right mark
now CBP is saying we are in a full-blown
emergency now it seems like we've been
hearing this for a long time six weeks
ago when we were down in the Del Rio
sector of the southern border in Texas
that sector which usually is pretty
small in terms of border crossings was
bursting at the seams but now it's
exponentially worse
so what more needs to happen for
Congress to get this and do something to
secure the border so Laura that's the
question we've been astounded alarm for
for a very long time that this is
absolutely a humanitarian and national
security crisis and Congress has failed
to do their job Laura it's it's
unbelievable to me that we're still
asking across the board what which what
can Congress do when we've been telling
Congress the experts that are living
this every single day from ice to the
Border Patrol to CBP they need to pass
meaningful legislation they need to
address the floor settlement agreement
and T V PRA they do that fun some bed
space and this crisis ends tomorrow they
know what they need to do we've been
telling them and they refuse to do what
they need to do now mark we're learning
even more about what yours and other
agencies are doing for these migrants
now HHS had been offering English
language courses legal services
bilingual services various forms of
entertainment for those who were
apprehended especially the young people
now CBP is now trying to buy purchase
2.2 million diapers for these migrant
kids now and I saw it being down at the
border via these are desperately needed
because agents themselves are acting as
caretakers they're not caretakers but
they're having to act as caretakers so
what do you say tonight to Democrats
like Alexander El Castillo Cortez who
wants to abolish ice because she thinks
well ice are the bad guys ice needs to
go because it's that
is not humanitarian not humanitarian
efforts so politicians like that law
that are absolutely misinformed and that
the the rhetoric that we if you talk
about abolishing ice it's absolutely
irresponsible let's talk about a
homeland security side investigation
side of ice last year alone
thirty four thousand criminal arrests
five thousand gang members arrested
thousands of cases of child smuggling
exploitation human trafficking they
seized 1.2 billion dollars in US
currency from illicit activity yeah I'd
like to talk to that young congresswoman
and have her tell me what's going to
happen if ice is abolished on that
enforcement and removal operations this
year to date 66,000 individuals have
been removed from this country Laura 90%
of those individual removed either had
we're convicted of additional crime are
charges pending so what I would say to
politicians like that you need to get
informed and stop the rhetoric out there
because it's not doing anybody any good
yeah well mark it's purposeful denial
it's obvious to anyone with these
staggering numbers 32 percent increase
140,000 people cross the border just in
the month of May as we just heard from
and okay but Democrat candidate Jill
Biden says well the following about the
crisis at the border
my god ordered your cummingandgoing
keratitis you just simply mystify shop
missive crisis created by the
administration and that's why the crisis
is created by trump mark that Laura that
is absolutely and look I'm trying to
choose my words carefully here but that
is absolutely absurd the crisis is being
created by our broken Asylum laws that
tells people yeah grab a kid and that's
a u.s. passport into this country and
once you get here you're gonna stay
Laura right now we have people that are
renting kids they're renting kids coming
across then that facilitators and the
American side are then sending the kids
back to be recycled to be rented again
to form fake families so they can come
into the United States
mark mark we have been mark we've been
talking about this for months and months
and months no matter how bad the facts
get no matter how much video we show
it's like it doesn't matter
so all they care about is demonizing
Trump look at these you know these
children are being kept in bands instead
of reunited with their parents when the
actual truth is children have no beds
because Congress will not allocate the
money to even build temporary facilities
to keep these kids so what what is I
supposed to do just release them into
society or HHS release them into society
to be trafficked I mean what is the
humanitarian response here but I'm just
getting a little bit sick of this it's
filled with lies and distortions only to
demonize Trump when we have runaway
judges that cause a lot of this problem
in in a Congress who doesn't do its job
it's just beyond comprehension
Lord you're absolutely right I agree
with you a hundred percent right now
we've asked Congress so that they won't
pass the laws that they need do to fix
this but we're asking for supplemental
the conditions of Border Patrol nineteen
thousand four thousand capacity of
nineteen thousand they have twenty five
hundred kids in the facilities it's
unsafe they
shouldn't be there were asking for a
supplemental to help HSS to help CVP and
ice to get additional bed space to
alleviate the humanitarian side of this
and Congress still sitting on their
hands mark I think until this issue gets
solved the administration should talk
about this every single day it's not
scare mongering it's not fear-mongering
it is the truth thank you for joining us